für Finnland war es ein
außerordentliches Jahr wir wollen jetzt
in die NATO
[Musik]
und ich komme nach Hause und frage was
ist das hast du gehört maximum hast du
gehört das was militärische Flug
da gibt es eine konkrete Geschichte ein
Bild ein persönliches Schicksal und auf
einmal wird einem das ganze grauen von
Krieg oder von Tod klar
fängt man fast
mein erster Gedanke war sind die Leute
sicher sind die Anlagen sicher haben wir
die Lage unter Kontrolle
üben hier den Häuserkampf
diese Einheit soll Finnlands Hauptstadt
verteidigen Helsinki schützen vor einem
Angriff
sie üben unter den Augen ihres
verteidigungs- die Richtung stimmt schon
meint der aber es gibt ja noch mehr
Training gewesen
angetreten vor Finnlands einzigem
4-sterne-general timo kiwinen ist
oberster Militär Herr über eine Armee
die im Notfall fast eine Million
Reservisten einziehen kann das ist jeder
sechste Einwohner
genau history we have in unserer
Geschichte gab es mehrere Kriege mit
Russland der Sowjetunion wir wissen alle
unser Nachbar ist eine starke Macht und
wir müssen bereit sein das Land zu
verteidigen
Umfragen sagt eine große Mehrheit der
Finnen regelmäßig sie würden auch selbst
mit der Waffe dafür kämpfen praktisch
jede und jeder hier hat jemanden in der
Familie der Wehrpflicht leistet oder
geleistet hat
rechter Fuß nach hinten sicherer Stand
leicht nach vorne beugen und dann tust
du was du tun musst
in den 90er Jahren hatten wir auch bei
uns eine Diskussion und wir wie die
meisten Staaten in Europa unsere
Landesverteidigung abbauen sollten aber
wir waren klug genug dass nicht zu tun
und jetzt zahlt sich das aus
200 Leopard Panzer hat der General
aktuell zur Verfügung und mit dem
Dienstwagen könnte er auch unterirdisch
fahren denn halb helsinki ist ein
einziger Bunker
hämisch wirken mit Blick auf den Zustand
der Bundeswehr will der Finne aber auf
keinen Fall nur Zweifel an der eigenen
Verteidigungsfähigkeit wie in
Deutschland soll es eben auch nicht
geben Ruhe und Sicherheit verkörpern das
erwarten Sie hier von ihm
denn der Nachbar im Osten ist nah gerade
mal zwei Stunden Fahrt von Helsinki bis
zur russischen Grenze über zunehmend
verweste Autobahnen es ist ruhig
geworden am Kontrollposten seit Finnland
russische Touristen nur noch in
Ausnahmefällen ins Land lässt die Duty
Free Geschäfte für Besucher aus dem
Osten längst geschlossen
Finnland hat im Zweiten Weltkrieg ein
Zehntel seines Territoriums an dieser
wird Union verloren die Menschen hier
haben viel erlebt
manchmal versuchen Russen hier rüber zu
kommen aber sie werden wieder
zurückgeschickt
über 1.300 km lang ist die gemeinsame
Grenze das ist so weit wie von Hamburg
nach Rom
gleiche hinten bei den Bäumen nur ein
paar Meter weiter beginnt Russland es
gibt viele Schilder hier betreten
verboten aber keinen Zaun wirklich
befestigt ist diese Grenze nicht
bloß nichts provozieren strikte
Neutralität das war jahrzehntelang das
finnische Rezept jetzt empfängt der
General die Botschafter der NATO-Staaten
in seiner Kaserne
für Finnland eine historische Zäsur
wir hatten erwartet dass die Diskussion
um einen NATO-Beitritt hochkocht aber
dass sich die öffentliche Meinung dazu
so schnell ändern würde das hätte
niemand gedacht
mittlerweile ist eine große Mehrheit in
Parlament und Bevölkerung für den
NATO-Beitritt Verteidigung geht uns alle
an steht auf den Armee Plakaten wir
wollen niemanden bedrohen sagt general
kiwinnen aber mit der NATO gibt es mehr
abschreckungspotenzial und Russland so
ergänzt er dann noch verstehe ja
offenbar nur harte macht
die Sprache der Militärs
stehen und drehen und los es sind
Kommandos ganz andere Art in dieser
Sporthalle an der Mosel Turnen verbindet
sagt Trainer Bernd aber ohne Olga käme
er dennoch nicht weiter sie ist nicht
nur ass am Reck sondern dolmetscht auch
für die anderen hier aus der Ukraine
dabei war die Sprache auch für sie
gerade noch so fremd
wie viel Deutsch sprichst du denn jetzt
so am Tag normalerweise
genau Deutsch ehrlich obwohl du
eigentlich mit dir Ukraine sprechen
könntest
viermal pro Woche Halt finden in der
Turnhalle für ein neues Leben weil das
alte nicht mehr existiert und das gilt
nicht nur für die Tochter hätten sie das
gedacht vor einem Jahr als sie fliehen
mussten sie mal heute hier sitzen in der
Sporthalle in Rheinland-Pfalz nein
ich habe keine
Ahnung
es war einfach so eine Million
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine leben hier
in Deutschland wo ist sie hin verschlägt
und wie es Ihnen geht hängt oft vom
Zufall ab das ist Region
so viele Erinnerungen ans eigene Haus
den Garten mit 16 Sorten Rosen die
Eltern der Mann der Bruder alle jetzt
weit weg mutig und flexibel die
deutsch-vokabeln an der Wand wie eine
Beschreibung ihrer Lage
Mami was können wir tun wenn Krieg kommt
hatte die Tochter gefragt wir setzen uns
ins Auto und fahren nach Westen hatte
die Mutter geantwortet es sollte stark
klingen nach einem Plan sowie Hannah
stojak für alles einen Plan hat auch
jetzt noch weil ich möchte selbständig
sein ja ich verstehe nicht mit
soziale Geld das ist wichtig weil das
ist eine große Teil von meinem Leben
meine Job meine Arbeit die Kinder die
Frau Dr steuert die kommt ja ab und zu
und die begleitet uns hier und wir
wollen sie heute noch mal kontrollieren
wie es ihm heute gegangen ist ja in der
Ukraine war sie zehn Jahre lang Ärztin
in einer Kinderklinik jetzt lebt sie von
Sozialhilfe und macht Praktikum bei
einem Hausarzt versuchen Sie auch bitte
noch einmal zu husten der würde sie am
liebsten gleich einstellen als
Nachfolgerin wenn er in Rente geht
Siri wie Kalle Wurzel auf Ukrainisch
[Musik]
doch dr stojak muss womöglich noch Jahre
Geduld haben bis sie hier wirklich
arbeiten darf kaum Angebote für Kurse
und Prüfungen und viel Unsicherheit
welche Arztausbildung bei uns anerkannt
wird
ich würde mir wünschen dass die
bürokratischen Hindernisse schneller zu
überwinden während denn die finde ich
für uns in Deutschland eigentlich
erbärmlich Hanna stojak spürt ohne
ständiges kämpfen tut sich wenig andere
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine im selben
Ort haben es weit weniger gut geschafft
sie leben seit Monaten in einem
ausrangierten Gasthof Zimmer zu dritt
auf 20 Quadratmeter
ich weiß nicht wie kann ich helfen auch
für eine die versucht alles im Griff zu
behalten ist es manchmal zu viel träumen
sie manchmal von der Ukraine
absolut
von was träumen sie dann
meine leben
ich will doch stark sein sagt sie für
meine Tochter
die ist angekommen in der Schule feiert
Olga ihren ersten Carneval
[Musik]
keine Bremse und bald tritt sie an im
Turnwettkampf um den moselpokal
es hat wieder länger gedauert jetzt ist
der Zeitplan in Gefahr
wer Robert Habeck folgt muss gut zu Fuß
sein er selbst liebt solche Bilder ein
Minister der sich keine Pause leisten
kann Gaskrise Energiesicherheit
Klimaschutz Habeck ist für alles
zuständig und für alles gleichzeitig
ich muss sagen ganz schön durchbrechen
Kantine Mittagessen gibt es bei ihm nie
sagen die Mitarbeiter manchmal schläft
er schlecht sagt er selbst aber der
permanente Ausnahmezustand im
Ministerium sei jetzt vorbei das macht
das einfacher also das sollte planbare
pausezeiten haben und nicht in ewigen
langen Telefonkonferenzen mit mir oder
untereinander ihre Wochenenden
gescheitert haben ein Alarm Jahr das
vieles geschreddert hat
beinahe auch seinen Ruf weil die Frage
aufkam ist Harbeck all dem gewachsen
mittlerweile wirkt der entspannt wenn
man mit ihm spricht schönes Büro schönes
Büro finde ich ist das für sie ein
Vorteil oder Nachteil so im Rampenlicht
zu stehen wie kein Wirtschaftsminister
vor ihnen das also als ich hier
reingekommen bin war ein riesen Ding von
Ludwig Erhardt nicht sicher nö als wenn
man bedenkt aber Energie Klima und
Wirtschaft gleichzeitig in dieser Zeit
also ich denke da nicht drüber nach das
ist die öffentliche Beobachtung und
Erklärung dessen was wir tun ist Teil
des Jobs das ist wieder was worüber ich
klage noch etwas was
was einem irgendwie besondere Freude
bereitet oder stolz macht und das ist
einfach Teil des Jobs und es gibt
einfach viel zu erklären viel erklären
dass es Stil und Strategie zugleich zwei
Mitarbeiterinnen mit Smartphone immer im
Schlepptau das Social Media Team des
Ministeriums im Grunde sagt sei er der
oberste press Lautsprecher im Haus das
Ministerium einen schier endloses
Labyrinth von Gängen für das sie hier
Lagepläne ausgeben in dem eine
Energiekrise zu managen war und auch
Fehler gemacht wurden also gasumlage
wenn ich das aussprechen soll es gab
keine Alternative es gab keine 30
Milliarden umgebaut zu retten es war der
einzige Weg den Markt Chemie zu halten
auch die für das Vertrauen der
Investoren dazu hat insofern war das
auch wenn wir später geändert haben in
dem Moment richtig dieser jetzt Umlage
geändert sie haben sehr zurückgenommen
mit der Gasanlage und dann zu sagen
jetzt gehe ich wieder voll raus ich
würde bereuen
wenn ich aus Angst vor Fehler nicht mehr
entscheiden würde keine Angst vor
Fehlern sagt der häufig aber natürlich
weiß er zu viele Fehler kann sich
niemand leisten in Brunsbüttel ist
Harbeck als Energieminister unterwegs
eröffnet ein weiteres schwimmendes
gasterminal dass der Winter in
Deutschland nicht dunkel und kalt wurde
nimmt er als Bestätigung seiner Arbeit
der klimaschutzminister Habeck hat es
schwer die Ladung hier kommt aus Abu
Dhabi ein langfristiger Großauftrag für
die Industrie auch die RWE Manager
Lächeln hier in die Kameras und ein
CDU-Mann lobt Habeck über den grünen
Klee er hatte auch bestimmte Ideologien
zur Seite geräumt um eben auch solche
Projekte die hier zu ermöglichen aber
weiträumig abgesperrt vor den Toren
rufen Sie Verrat
das ist ein klimaverbrechen also ich
glaube die grüne Politik hat hier
versagt ganz ehrlich
Harbeck Habeck du warst mal okay doch
dann kam RWE singen sie in der
Klimabewegung für den Grünen Minister
dürfte das die größte Herausforderung
werden wenn nicht ein massives Problem
aber nochmal zurück zu dem Song du warst
mal okay da spricht ja durchaus
Bewunderung raus aber gleichzeitig auch
tiefe Enttäuschung jetzt das muss ihnen
doch was was mit ihnen machen aber ich
will da keine härter reinbringen ich
habe ja schon gesagt dass man die
jeweiligen Rollen verstehen muss und
auch akzeptieren muss aber wenn es eine
Enttäuschung gibt dann liegt die in
weiten Teilen Informiertheit nach einem
Jahr Krisenmanagement muss er nicht nur
seiner Partei zeigen wie er die
Klimaziele einhalten will Robert Habeck
wird jetzt daran gemessen ob er die
deutsche Energiewende schafft
kein Ort hat im letzten Jahr so
profitiert wie es da Wanger in Norwegen
Europas Öl und gashauptstadt wo selbst
die Kinderspielplätze aus alten
Pipelines bestehen aus einem
verschlafenen Fischerdorf wurde Europas
energiehauptstadt und nichts mehr ist so
wie früher neben den Holzhäusern gibt es
schicke Weinbars neue Bürokomplexe und
natürlich ein ölmuseum aus der ganzen
Welt sind sie hierher gekommen weil
insta-wanger viel zu verdienen ist
ich glaube in Deutschland ist auch der
Pragmatismus eingekehrt dass man jetzt
nicht von heute auf morgen einfach auf
erneuerbare Energien und auf Wasserstoff
umschalten kann irgendwo da unten liegt
Europas Öl und Gas
mit dem Hubschrauber raus aufs offene
Meer eine Stunde Flug dann tauchen die
ungetümer auf die Norwegen reich gemacht
haben und gerade immer reicher machen
das Land ist in den letzten Monaten zur
mit Abstand größten Energielieferanten
der deutschen geworden ein ganzer
Kontinent steht plötzlich Schlange
da drüben machen wir gerade eine neue
Erkundungsbohrung
und das da ist auch alles Umsatz
Karl Johnny herschweg auf
inspektionstour der Vorstandschef der
größten privaten Öl- und Gasfirma des
Landes sagt stolz wir halten Europa am
laufen
19 Milliarden Dollar will sein Konzern
hier investieren in neue Öl und
Gasfelder Förderung rund um die Uhr
immer mehr immer effektiver da drüben
ist Schottland auf der anderen Seite
Norwegen über uns
20.000 Tonnen Stahl und hier unten
bohren Sie drei Kilometer tief
Öl und Gas in einem Labyrinth von
Leitungen diese Bohrinsel allein
produziert jeden Tag so viel um die
Tanks einer halben Millionen Autos zu
füllen für die Manager geht es schlicht
um Angebot und Nachfrage und die
Nachfrage ist enorm
wir wollen hier produzieren bis alles
leer ist das hier ist ausgelegt für eine
Produktion bis 2045
fällt die Nachfrage
investieren wir weniger
uns also wenn wir weniger konsumieren
dann werden sie aufhören zu bohren
weniger fördern
selbst schuld also sagt der ölverkäufer
für ihn ist das was er hier aus dem
Meeresboden holt vor allem ein Geschäft
es riecht nach Industrie
wer hier draußen arbeitet verdient gut
zwei Wochen offshore vier Wochen frei
es gibt Jim Sauna Musikraum und vor
allem reichhaltig zu essen und doch
bleibt es Leben auf einem Pulverfass
diese Uhr muss man die ganze Zeit tragen
damit man getrackt werden kann und immer
klar ist wo man gerade ist und dann im
Schrank alle haben griffbereit so einen
Überlebensanzug fürs kalte Nordseewasser
denn sie wissen hier sollte mal etwas
schief gehen dann kann das potentiell
katastrophale Folgen haben das gesamte
System steht unter enormem Druck Gas Öl
Wasser werden hier gemeinsam aus der
Tiefe nach oben gepresst und noch auf
der Bohrinsel voneinander getrennt eine
Gaspipeline und eine für Öl führen zum
Festland jedes Leck hätte furchtbare
Konsequenzen auch für die Umwelt
die Sicherheitsregeln hier sind streng
und die Angst vor Sabotage groß viel in
Norwegen hängt ab von der Öl und
Gasindustrie die Zeit 80% Steuern an den
Staat wenn hier die Kasse klingelt dann
geht es Norwegen gut
und dennoch wächst auch im Land selbst
die Kritik an unfassbaren gewinnen
vervierfacht seit es Krieg gibt in
Europa Norwegen ein Profiteur
vielleicht aktuell aber während Corona
haben wir viel verloren es geht halt
hoch und runter und das sind wichtig
dass der Markt immer den genauen Preis
setzt
wenn der Preis oben ist dann wollen alle
einen Rabatt wenn er unten ist dann
wollen sie ihn Zahlen
Öl und Gasgeschäft irgendwann wird es
das nicht mehr geben das ist ihnen hier
klar das Wort Energiewende sagen sie
sogar auf Deutsch
aber bis dahin davon ist Karl Johnny
Herrsching überzeugt wird es noch lange
dauern bis dahin wird Europa ihn und
Norwegen brauchen aktuell mehr denn je
der russische Krieg gegen die Ukraine
hat viele Leben verändert überall und er
wird noch viele Leben verändern und sie
prägen die Gesichter der Zeitenwende
[Musik]